in the world of Zootopia humans never  happened  welcome to settle a modern civilized  world that is entirely animal large and  small fast and slow but the truth is  Zootopia isn't perfect and just like our  world not everyone gets along we have  fourteen missing mammal cases this is  priority number what's gotta be somebody  to find my in I will find out oh thank  you  you should try cow you is I deal  Nichols wild you can help me solve a  case Hey  all right I know we got  just heard officer Hopps taking the cave  mayor Lionheart is just gonna be so just  where - ah rainforest district fine into  hunger  hi Miami bring him home to me and my  babies please